does anybody remember a thing
called brexit anybody remember that it's
about 20 minutes ago less than two
months ago the British voted to leave
the European Union remember that nor how
the world economy was going to collapse
as a result because they didn't want the
EU telling them how to run their entire
freaking country EU was dictating to
them immigration policies and everything
else and not to mention the economic
aspects of the European Union so the
British decided they we're not going to
participate in that anymore and began a
process to be they voted to begin the
process to be removed from the European
Union you remember the next day that the
news media was screeching at the top of
their lungs as the stock market
plummeted you don't remember this just a
few months ago not even two months ago
and I actually was the thumbing through
some tweets about five o'clock this
morning like I have no life apparently
but and I tweeted that by the middle of
August which is where we are none of you
will even be able to spell brexit much
remember much let's remember what it is
have you noticed have you thought about
brexit have you worried that your
retirement account was going to collapse
and that the entire US economy and world
economy was going to come to an end
because the British didn't want to
participate in the European Union
anymore have you heard anything about it
unless you're in Britain no unless
you're in the UK you haven't heard boo
about it because it's a non-issue it was
a non-issue then but this 24 hours a day
we must make
newse if there's not news news channels
its driving it's driving us to
distraction in our culture they are now
worried on every major news feed this
afternoon you know what the make all all
of the world is concentrating in every
major news feed in America on the red
marks on Michael Phelps body they're
worried about cupping so apparently
you're probably going to lose all of
your retirement account because of
cupping now that could happen the entire
US economy could be in flux over cupping
unbelievable I mean we really need to
get our own lives people to where you're
not so tuned into this stuff now I'm
around media and I'm on the air
obviously I'm not technically media
because this is the Dave Ramsey show so
it's not like it's objective or
something it's my opinion that's why
they call it the Dave Ramsey show so
it's not like it's you know I'm gonna
try I have no journalism standard in the
sense I'm supposed to be somehow
objective I'm not objective it's my
opinion and I'm right because I own the
show so shut up it's like my house my
rules House Rules so you know old school
right but you know it and I know I'm on
all of them I go on CNN and Fox
regularly I was on Good Morning America
the other day and I'm not mad at any of
those folk they're all nice folks a lot
of my friends of mine I think they're
great people I'm looking the guy right
now on Fox it's a great guy he's just a
buddy of mine just a good they're good
people but you know some of y'all need
but keep in mind that if they haven't
got something to scare you about or make
you angry about they haven't got
anything to talk about that's going to
get ratings and so you need to
understand that the way you build wealth
is you do not use the evening news or
CNN or Fox to set the tone of your
emotions around your invest
if you're thinking of changing your
investing patterns but cause you're
watching the news you need to turn off
the news my friend Zig Ziglar used to
say get he would get up every morning
and read the newspaper and read the
Bible so he could tell what both sides
were doing hey you know you really have
to think about that that way you have to
look at this differently and say my
investing is going to be done based on
my intellect and an act of my will to
consistently every single month no
matter what the news is reporting I'm
going to be putting money into my 401k
I'm going to be putting money in my
growth stock mutual funds I'm going to
be paying off my home so that it's paid
for and I own it regardless of what
these clowns do to manipulate or screw
up this economy you are in charge of
your destiny and it turns out that you
know when brexit happened you remember
what they did all the people cannot say
oh I'm glad I bought gold for about two
days you were glad you bought gold now
gold sucks again and nobody's talking
about that except me a horrible
investment because it's based on either
fear or greed and there is no possible
way that makes for a quality investment
portfolio and that's my strategy you
have to be using numbers and histories
and and you know well you know Dave
where do you think you're going to get
over 10 percent in the coming years with
the current crisis that we're facing
you know the crisis's we're facing now
are different what are you pregnant
I mean seriously there's no difference
there's always a crisis there's always a
bunch of people running around with a
glass-half-full and a few a glass
half-empty a few of us got glasses that
are half-full that's it the current
crisis there's no way that these comic
can maintain they were saying that when
I came on the air you know what the Dow
was when I came on the air 25 years ago
3,000 it could never maintain
if it ever goes over 10,000 the economy
will just implode the whole thing I'll
just fall down on itself if it goes over
10,000 now they're saying that about
20,000 right so everybody's got this
thing figured out where their life is
screwed up and if not it's going to be
screwed up somewhere in the future so
where am i investing I'm investing in
good growth stock mutual funds you know
why cuz they have a great track record
future returns are not necessarily going
to be caused by past history past
history is not necessarily an indicator
of future returns well that's true it's
not necessarily but it's about the only
indicator you got and by the way that's
a dumb but statement that the government
makes you put on all your securities
transactions they don't make you sign
that with a house when you buy a house
you don't have to sign a piece of paper
that says well you know houses have not
always gone up in value and your house
is not guaranteed to go up in value they
don't make you sign that do they no but
when you buy an investment you got
43,000 pieces of paperwork because the
government is scared of death that you
haven't got any sense because some
people don't have any sense or that
somehow you're gonna get screwed because
somebody told you your investments are
going to go up you know past history is
no guarantee of future returns well it's
not a guarantee but it is an indicator
that's why you buy a house in a
neighborhood that's called a good
neighborhood because the past is an
indicator of the future that's why when
some guy has done drugs for 14 years you
don't hire him to work for you because
his past is an indicator of his future
that's why when some guy sleeps around
all over town then he wants to date your
daughter the answer is no because the
past is an indicator of the future yes
the past is an indicator of the future
to say otherwise only the government
would say that with a straight face and
go past is not an indicator of the
future well of course it is you stupid
fools of course it is it's a it's about
as good an indicator for forecasting and
business or anything else as we possibly
possibly have that's why I'm so
comfortable when some kind of crap like
brexit comes along and everybody's
screaming like a beagle chasing a rabbit
coming to an end but I'm not gonna panic
about it matter of fact when it drops
down I'm really tempted to drop a
serious chunk of money in right then
because I'm that sure it's gonna come
back up so here we are the middle of
August and I just had to remind you I
told you so
Breck's its history your life didn't
change keep investing don't slow down
and yes past history is an indicator of
future returns otherwise is stupid
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you can
do this you know that really is a
message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income on a five
hundred thousand dollar economy